[Musique]
le retour de l'alsace pour fêter le
centenaire de son rattachement à la
france il y a quelques mois cela était
encore de la politique fiction pourtant
aujourd'hui c'est une option bien réel
si la décision reste bien sûr entre les
mains du gouvernement
les présidences des deux départements
alsaciens soutenue par de nombreux
locaux travaillent en ce sens il y a
deux ans des conseils départementaux
haut-rhinois et bas-rhinois affiché leur
volonté de rendre à l'alsace une réalité
institutionnelle
ces douze derniers mois furent ceux
d'une intense activité pour y parvenir
il bien au non avec frédéric berry nous
portions un projet qui était celui de la
sortie de l'alsace du grand est au mois
de novembre 2017
lors d'une rencontre avec le président
de la république le président de la
république nous a dit on peut imaginer
une identité particulière pour l'alsace
mais à une condition c'est qu'elle reste
dans le grand est
nous sommes des élus républicains nous
sommes alsacien nous avons décidé avec
frédéric biri de tenter cette aventure
avec le gouvernement à savoir de
travailler ensemble sur un projet de
collectivité alsace les élus et laborde
donc un projet de collectivité
alsacienne basé sur l'échelon
départemental renforcé de nouvelles
compétences aidé par la région et l'état
une déclaration commune cap vers
l'alsace est signée en février par 130
élus et personnalités alsaciennes au
printemps une consultation citoyenne
rassemble quelque 13000 participation
qui viennent appuyer le projet
parallèlement le gouvernement confie au
préfet marx la réalisation d'un rapport
sur l'avenir institutionnel de l'alsace
la machine est lancée
je crois que le rapport marque ça a été
un un élément important dans le
processus il faut le souligner puisque
suite à ce rapport
madame gouro ministre auprès du ministre
d'état de l'intérieur a été nommé pour
porter et mener à terme le dossier de la
zac en effet d'ici mi octobre
madame gouro devra faire une proposition
au gouvernement si les négociations ont
lieu en ce moment même et qu'il est trop
tôt pour crier victoire
le projet alsace aura fait la
démonstration que l'union de tous les
alsaciens a été déterminante dans cette
mobilisation
les haut rhinois et les bas rhinois sur
ce projet pour l'alsace sont unis et ça
n'a malheureusement jamais été les cas
précédemment
d'où l'échec du référendum d'où aussi le
fait que il ya trois ans au moment de la
dissolution dans le grand-est personne
n'a réagi
aujourd'hui les haut rhinois et les bas
rhinois ont compris que pour l'avenir
que pour développer le territoire
alsacien
il fallait être unis le retour du nom
alsace serait déjà un grand progrès pour
nombre d'alsaciens blessé par sa
disparition lors de la réforme 2015
mais le projet défendu par les
départements se veut bien plus qu'une
simple restauration il s'agit de la
création d'une alsace politique c'est un
projet d'une alsace ouverte ouverture
ses voisins allemands suisses une alsace
ouverte sur l'europe mais pour arriver à
une collectivité qui est une réelle
capacité à agir en interne mais aussi
avec ses voisins nous avons besoin de
compétences et parmi ses compétences la
coopération transfrontalière
l'apprentissage des langues
la compétence dans le domaine des routes
nationales voilà donc les compétences
que nous réclamons et dont nous vous
avons besoin mais nous avons besoin
également de compétences qui nous
viendrait de la région le tourisme
et puis des compétences dans le domaine
de l'économie alors pourquoi et
qu'est-ce que cela va changer dans le
quotidien
et bien tout simplement pour demain
avoir une
elle capacité à agir en d'alsace pouvoir
mieux travailler avec nos voisins
allemands suisses et surtout créer de
l'emploi développer l'économie
le rapport marque évoque différentes
pistes institutionnel pour permettre
cette évolution de la fusion des
départements en un seul à une
collectivité à statut particulier en
passant par la création d'un syndicat
mixte regroupant différentes
collectivités
mais qu'importe le contenant pourvu que
le contenu soit là la demande qui est la
nôtre aujourd'hui avant tout à l'état ce
sont les compétences et quand ces
compétences nous les auront obtenues de
la part de l'état eh bien nous verrons
avec le gouvernement qu'elle est
l'entité institutionnel qui sera la plus
adéquate nous avec frédéric bihr et nous
pensons aujourd'hui très fortement une
collectivité à statut particulier
mais ce qui nous importe avant tout
c'est que la future collectivité
d'alsace la future heureux collectivités
que nous construisons ait des
compétences qui nous permettent d'agir
efficacement depuis fin août les
rencontres avec la ministre jacqueline
gourault s'enchaînent objectif de ces
négociations mettre au point la solution
la plus adaptée
nous avons rencontré une ministre qui
est très ouverte qui est très attentive
à la situation de l'alsace qui connaît
très bien le dossier et nous avons
rencontré une ministre aussi qui est
pragmatique elle a été à l'écouté
il s'agit maintenant pour nous de
poursuivre la négociation avec
jacqueline gourault et avec le
gouvernement pour nous assurer que le
projet qui demain pourrait sortir à
l'issue de ces négociations est bien un
projet d'une alsace forte avec des
compétences qui nous permettent d'agir
et pas juste une alsace de façade
les rencontres vont se poursuivre et la
ministre faire une proposition au
gouvernement à la mi octobre
jacqueline gourault nous a dit que le
gouvernement devrait se déterminer d'ici
la fin du mois d'octobre donc jamais
l'alsace n'a été aussi proche